ich habe so eine karte entdeckt und da
steht drauf klar kann es auch toastbrot
osten ist dann halt toastbrot
wir fangen an mit dem heutigen video
hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu der be nice challenge das
heißt ich muss nicht sein
obwohl ich eigentlich nicht sein will
übrigens unbedingt besser wenn der 3
heute will ich das heißt dass am ersten
12 di luca schabram für die be nice
channels habe ich mir heute ein video
von youtube ausgesucht da muss ich
wirklich sagen die ist nicht komplett
ich muss nicht sein eine meiner
kompletten lieblings youtuber rinnen
muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben katja
krasser witz hey
die ist super wir schauen uns erst mal
den titel von dem video an und zwar mein
eigener song alter das ist super katja
mensch dein eigener sorgen ich bin mir
sicher dass das ein mega gutes lied wird
die tags von dem video an und zwar katja
glaser witz ist vom lied lab katja
krawitz und da muss ich wirklich bis
jetzt sagen super
klasse tags bisher also real talk bisher
waren die tags super kann man so stehen
lassen jetzt schauen wir allerdings mal
weiter und zwar couscous küssen kissing
na ja auch super text klasse doch jetzt
wenn wir uns die nächsten suchbegriffe
für das video mal anschauen sehen wie
puppen es sexy hot geil
naja
klasse
hab ich überhaupt nicht oberflächlich
das wäre so wie wenn ich in meinem text
schreiben würde
augen nase mund penis aber meine damen
und herren katja glaser witz wäre nicht
meine lieblings aller supertoll mega
hyper beste youtube denn ich nicht
wissen würde wie die community katja
liebt deswegen schauen wir befreien uns
das video anschauen noch mal ganz kurz
in die kommentare was haben wir denn
hier oh mein gott ich bin so aufgeregt
tötet mich nicht
kann ja keiner möchte nicht töten du
bist super sam sommer ist der produzent
körper mensch sam sommer hat doch dieses
tolle lied what von bibi gemacht und
wäre doch klasse wenn er auch das sorry
aber wen der song du bist dann porno
porno bau frei und nagt das kann ich
nicht verstehen wie gegen katja glaser
wird einem youtuber rinnen mit dem
content des sich hier der es hier der
ist nicht jeder es hier ja das ist wie
kann man denn da so etwas
oberflächliches und blödes reinschreiben
jahren krebs kommt ich würde sagen wir
schauen jetzt mal ins video rein denn
die kommentare hier
sind überhaupt nicht passen der song
wird bestimmt super
katja du hast doch keinen fetten bauch
man sieht doch hier die sixpacks schon
richtig raus kommen ich will es auch
interessant dass hier recht einfachen
weißer balken ist weil sie dort
anscheinend nackt ist also katja muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen finde ich super
dass du dann aber wir schauen uns dieses
kunststück mal der bauch
warum räkelt sie sich das
so gut vor der kamera war weil ich finde
es klasse wenn man seinen körper zeigt
und präsentiert
ja
finde ich auch schön dass sein
ich habe tränen in ca
ich weiß nicht ob man das sieht aber ich
hab manchmal einfach meine sentimentalen
phasen werde ich meine lieblings youtube
erhielt weil so gut sei immer dran
denken freunde
man kann auch toastbrot osten ist ein
halt toastbrot schreibt mir bitte
unbedingt videos in die kommentare unten
zu denen ich auch eine be nice challenge
machen soll also auf die ich komplett
net reagieren soll aber jetzt schauen
wir erstmal meine lieblings youtuber
dann weiter
[Musik]
also nicht wissen was ich habe euch
nämlich gesagt dass ich ein sehr gutes
projekt planen ein riesenprojekt für
mich wird es noch irgend ein
riesenprojekt wollte ich schon seit ich
klein war und es ist klasse finde ich
toll dass katja wirklich ihre ziele
verfolgt seitdem sie klein ist der
brauch es da aber auch fisch also muss
man sagen klasse neben fetten bauch hat
sie ja gar nicht das ist sie hat ja im
super körper also ist ja meine lieblings
youtube
ich weiß eigentlich dass einfach nicht
machen weil ich bin katja und ich bin
was katja jetzt mama halblang hier für
mich hat ja bist du die beliebteste
youtuber in in deutschland und ich habe
jetzt auch mal keine kosten und mühen
gescheut und einfach mal das web
durchsucht statista durchsucht
nach statistiken werden die täglich die
beliebtesten youtuber in deutschland
sind und da bin ich wirklich auf diese
statistik gegenstoß meine damen und
beliebt dass der youtuber in deutschland
platz 1 katja zwei alle anderen katja du
dass er ist hier das ist von deutschland
da kann das es ne du bist die
beliebteste youtube waren glaub an dich
aber wissen sie ja hast mich beleidigt
ich mache hat ja nein
wir lieben dich
aus unserem tiefsten herz
we love you katja i love you guys
freunde bitte schreibt in die kommentare
we love you katja because we love you
katja
was mache ich hier macht was ihr wollt
ich werde einfach einige typen von den
nicht für die tollen kategorien sind von
der bösen zu mir
gehörst du zu den tollen katja es war
gerade mit meiner stimme los ich habe
das häufig wenn ich meine lieblings über
schauer und qualitativ hochwertigen
content dass meine stimme versagt es tut
mir leid ich bitte dies zu entschuldigen
[Musik]
normalerweise suchen wir sowas auf das
gesicht ran aber katja meine lieblings
youtube drinnen summt auf ihre brüste
run finde ich aber klasse weil die sind
ja in einer gewissen form ihr gesicht
und fußpilz gegenseite tippen steht
zweimal in den text und gesicht keinmal
also weiß man ganz klar worauf hier die
priorität gesetzt wird
da hat ja wenn du es nicht machen
möchtest dann lass uns doch auch bitte
also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich bin ein
riesiger fan von ich habe hier fanpage
von mir
das ist meine pizza luca ich war ja ich
habe ich habe ich habe fanpage von dir
ein kondom mit einem loch ich verbitte
drin weil safety first aber nein katja
ich als als riesiger fan von dir und ich
glaube ich spreche da auch für deine
fangemeinde
wir müssen also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen hat was ich machen möchte so etwas
nicht sagen möchte dann muss das nicht
tun denn wir halt katja nieters
wir hätten dort aber wisst ihr was ist
den 50.000 oder mehr und sagen sogar
aktionären 1 machte es nicht besser und
ich alleine in meinem kopf
das ist die richtige entscheidung hat ja
wenn dir alle menschen sagen mach es
nicht aber dein kopf sagte ihr macht ist
dann sollte man es tun und so lieben wie
dich katja solange es nicht komplett ich
bin schon wolle habe wie es ist es okay
und die anderen setzten sich cosimo la
vie niemand einen streit
nein niemand ist luca was was du dich
hier das ist wirklich wenn ich euch das
jetzt schon sagen euer kopf ist einfach
nur so und 17 es wird einfach so sein
aber ich bin stolz darauf und ich bin
happy zu ich zeige euch jetzt mal eine
aufnahme
hat ja das war wundervoll dein eigener
song
wow
was eine
selbstbewusster
junge dame
die ihre träume verfolgt
nur gut werden ich fange ihnen schon
bevor ich überhaupt diese chance hat er
hat dann so eine erwartung wenn ich euch
jetzt nicht mehr zähler
und am ende erwartet die frau des
krassen lied von mir ja und dann kommt
ein scheiß also half nichts die die zu
krasse erwarten hier katja hat nicht so
die zu krass hohen erwartungen katja wir
stellen keine erwartungen an dich also
wenn du deinen traum erfüllen möchte
seinen eigenen song zu machen dann kann
er derek hahn gar nicht scheiße werden
katja es von dir du bist meine absolute
lieblingsstadt oberin ich kaufe mir den
sorgen egal was es kostet außer dass es
ist jetzt irgendwie so baby preismäßig
aber ich bin ganz ehrlich katja also
jetzt mal ich ich ich ich als katja
neller ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
werde in den laden stürmen ich werde
dafür kämpfen wir den cup saison zu
holen
das meine ich komplett ernst die
zugkraft
katja du kannst super toll singen das
hat man doch auch schon in deinem
ausschnitt gesehen
ja da hat man doch gesehen dass das kann
teuer werden bei deiner engelsstimme
katja das war's jetzt ihr vom video
meine damen und herren ich habe das
video gerade mal eine minute 42 geschaut
aber ich habe so viel zu kommentieren
gehabt bei meiner lieblings youtube in
katja wie gesagt freunde haut ihr bitte
in die kommentare we love katja wenn ihr
richtiger kater seid und wie zu beginn
gesagt werde ich jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz euch das komplette merchandise
vorstellen was in dem am 11 12
das merchandise dort rein kommen und
zwar das erste ist sogar mein
lieblingsstück eigentlich das wetter
hier
da haben wir eingesteckt hallo mein name
ist oder so ein paar sonderzeichen als
wenn das zensiert war weil ich wollte
erstmal mein name ist luca machen aber
ich denke wenn dann leute damit rum
laufen dann gegen andere leute heißt
auch luca und die person heißt
vielleicht gar nicht luca die zweite
sache die in den shop kommen wird ist
dieser rudi da habe ich mal ein bisschen
was neues probiert und zwar seht ihr
schon da sind hier an den ärmeln ein
bisschen weißes mützchen so hellem gelb
und ein bisschen helping ich wollte
einfach mal so einen vielfarbigen rudi
machen war ein bisschen schwierig vor
allem diese nähte hier vorne schön
hinzukriegen weil ich dachte ja immer so
ein bisschen sehr krass auf qualität ich
weiß dann haben wir hier den luke
hrustic also auch eingestickt natürlich
weil ich das klima finden als wenn
irgendwas bedruckt ist also dass sie
wird auf jeden fall auch launischen dann
haben wir hier noch einen zweiter der
launischen wird ihr wisst freunde es ist
kalte jahreszeit da trägt man erst
retter und polizisten vetter print drauf
von rechts unten nach links oben wo luke
drauf steht für luxus das ist an der
stelle und print und kein stück weil
wenn das geschickt worden wäre hätte der
sweater so irgendwie 300.000 euro
gekostet und etwas dunkleres blau fast
schon schwarz und mit diesem weißen
print drauf ich hatte sonst übrigens
immer patches wo luca draufstand ich
wollte diesmal allerdings einfach nur
den smiley haben und wir haben es jetzt
einfach so gemacht dass der patch quasi
hier am ärmel quasi bündig über geht bin
ich auch ein bisschen hochwertiger und
neusser ehrlich gesagt und dann haben
wir auch noch ein t shirt design fast am
ersten zwölf tischen wird da bin ich
besonders stolz drauf denn das ist so
stone washed also ich weiß nicht ob ihr
das seht aber das hat so ein bisschen
sonja sonnen etwas zerstört zerstörten
look sage ich mal jedes shirt was
bestellt wie das ein unikat also jedes
sich irgendwie von den
streifen und so hier anders aus weil das
halt in steinen gewaschen wird
da haben wir hier auch ein print drauf
lucio haben wir so einnehmen orange
gewählt weil ich finde das passt ganz
gut zu diesem dunklen ton wollte ich
auch ersticken lassen würde allerdings
bei einem shirt eh schon teurer werden
und die sache ist dadurch dass das tor
stets costa shirt ihr glaube ich so 23
euros mehr als normale shirts in meinem
shop aber freunde wisst bescheid ich
möchte dass es nicht so richtig
merchandise ist sondern mehr halt
wirklich mode mehr oder weniger und
deswegen ja also bin ich ultra geil aber
wenn es euch zu teuer ist kann ich auch
verstehen aber ich wollte halt unbedingt
mal diesen stone washed lockt hier
probieren und ich finde das mega geil
geworden übrigens sind alle sachen die
launischen werden
ein bisschen over size das heißt wenn
ihr sonst größe m hat will ich diesmal
größe s bestellen wenn jetzt normal
tragen wollte aber wenn ihr also ein
bisschen aufpasst steht zum beispiel bei
mir gehen die ärmel jetzt auch schon
hier über die hände weg dann einfach
eure normale größe bestellen
und ja es werden auch noch socken lauten
daher werde ich euch aber noch keine
bilder zeigen das seht ihr dann am
ersten zwölfter im shop an der stelle
würde ich das video jetzt allerdings
auch beenden meine damen und herren wenn
ihr mir auf instagram twitter snap chat
und so folgt wisst dass ich da rund um
die uhr eigentlich irgendwas neues zum
merchandise und zum buch kostet das buch
leider nicht am ersten zwölfter schaffen
wir leider nicht wir arbeiten auf der
einen seite wirklich einen hochdruck
daran dass das buch im dezember noch
kommen wird das werden wir
wahrscheinlich hinkriegen aber auf der
anderen seite wollen wir halt auch dass
es so perfekt wie nur eben möglich wird
und wollen uns dahingehend halt auch ein
bisschen zeit damit lassen aber bevor
ich jetzt noch lange drum rum lama will
ich an dieser stelle auch das video
beenden ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
weil es getan hat las man lag da wie
gesagt schreib mir an den videos in den
kommentaren auf die ich reagieren soll
und jetzt kommt das auto
vom video hier können jetzt jemanden
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten mal
einen shop ausschenken jetzt findet ihr
zwei andere videos und benny schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]